everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're gonna be looking at
a game seven from the 2014 World Chess
Championship give you a quick recap
magnus carlsen is up a game last game in
game number six there were two big
blunders magnus carlsen had a monumental
mistake moving his king to d2 but vision
on responded with a blunder as well
Magnus Carlsen took advantage of that
second blender and went on to a secure
victory and go up a full point so we're
halfway through there are 12 total games
we've gone through six Magnus Carlsen is
up a full points on vision on so one win
in front of him going into Game seven
Magnus Carlsen actually plays Dwight
twice in a row and then they'll
alternate through the end machine on
will end on the white pieces so Magnus
Carlsen gets us started in game number
seven with the white pieces we see
Magnus start out with pawn to e4 which
we've seen before vision on usually
opting for that pawn to d4 Magnus
Carlsen a little bit more of aggressive
player especially in the opening pawn to
e4 pawn to e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop
to b5 this is the right Lopez there's
some we're opening to what we've seen
before both sides you can really tell
the different openings that they've
studied that they prepared for this is
definitely one of those vision on
specifically you know the Berlin defense
we've already seen this before and we
talked about in the previous video but -
Carlsen knows the Berlin defense maybe
better than anyone so always interesting
to see vichy and on play the Berlin
defense against a master of this opening
but again you can really tell that Vichy
and on has prepared for this events
there's many different variations many
different famous games that have played
different types of Berlin defense so he
can study all those and be very very
well prepared Magnus Carlsen decides to
go for castling and then we see the
knight taking on e4 yes black does gain
material but it's gonna be hard for him
to hold on to that material we do see
pawn here - d4 and now the Knights gonna
come back here and after the bishop
exchange now we're gonna see this pawn
taking here on e5 getting that material
back now the knight comes back here to
f5 and this the next move was pretty
interesting Magnus Carlsen had two
different options he could bring his
queen to e2 he could also bring his
Queen to d8
and he opted to go ahead and for the
exchange now I think he did this
you know previously he had exchanged the
Queens off the board and things went
well for him he ended up with his minor
pieces and in his rooks going on for the
victory so I think that's probably why
he did it maybe if that hadn't happened
he would have tried to keep his Queen on
board try for her Queen d2 which is
completely fine still tries to hold on
to this semi open file with this pawn
pressure on the e-file but again I think
he kind of looked in the past and said
it'd be a little bit easier game for me
I'm better at the in game than probably
in the world so just decided to go ahead
and exchange on d8 h3 the King coming
back here to EA doesn't want to be on
this open file for Magnus Carlsen to
continue to attack Knight to c3
continuing development pawn to h5
machine on doesn't want to have to worry
about Magnus Carlsen pushing up to
forward on the King side and again when
your opponent's Queens are off the board
you don't have to worry too much about
King safety a lot of times you'll even
get your King involved into the game
centralizing that game moving more
towards the in game and so he's not too
worried about the fact that he can't
move his King and so okay doesn't worry
doesn't have to worry too much about his
pawns not doing anything and staying at
home they can be pretty aggressive so
pawn to h5 Bishop here to f4 completely
in development from Magnus Carlsen
Bishop to e7 rook over here to d1 again
rooks always do better on open file
since semi-open files they can just
control more space it's not about the
pieces you have it's about what they're
doing for your game and so you always
want to optimize the pieces on board
that's why Knights usually do better in
the middle of the board they have more
squares to go to roofs are always going
to do better in these semi open and open
files also behind kind of your pawns as
you kind of push those forward so Bishop
here to e6 and then Knights here to a g5
kind of get into at the home of the King
ahead for black here but what's
interesting is this opening has been
played many times by high-level players
earlier this year
Anish yuri actually played this exact
line and vision on actually played a
very similar line just a few years ago
against Nakamura so both of these
players are very familiar with these
lines and actually
playing extremely fast through the first
25 hooves which were not there yet
vision on took only 30 minutes and
magnus carlsen took about 20 minutes so
there they're definitely flying through
these moves that's pretty fast for 25
minutes in a high-level match like this
so a rook here to h6 not really
deviating from much of the lines that
we've seen from the nice giri game not
too long ago this year we now see pawn
here to a g3 the bishops now going to
come down on g5 and take now we do see
an exchange off the board the rook here
to g6 and then pawn pushing forward to
h4 a little bit of protection on that
Bishop right there pawn here to f6 we do
see an exchange right here and then the
bishops forced to come back here to f4
the Knights now going to take the palm
pushes forward can't take this Knight
because again this rook is pinning down
the pawn to this King the roofs gonna
swing over here the King's gonna come up
here to f2 centralizing a little bit
also just doesn't want to have to deal
with the pawn being pinned down so now
he can take if he wants to
first this chignon decides he wants to
go ahead and exchange off the board and
now the night it's gonna come back here
to f5 since it was being attacked an
adding another layer of attack on the
square here on g3 so the risk of
swinging over here to h1 attacking that
pawn and now that bishops gonna take
over here on a1 just signifying that you
know manage Carlsen can go ahead and
take this material so they're just kind
of trading blows back and forth back and
forth right now now the bishop is gonna
come back here to e6 the pawn comes up
here to a g4 threatening this knight the
Knights going to come back here to d6
and all of a sudden we see the first 25
move so Magnus Carlsen plays rook to h7
and this is the exact opening that we
see from a nice Deary earlier in the air
and it's crazy that these players
studies so many games to the level of
detail that they remember the first 25
moves in a game and they can go through
them very very quickly you know every
now and then making sure that they're
not missing anything but this is the
same setup as before now in that game
the play was pawn here to f5 a pretty
aggressive line a white thing continued
with pawn
you 2g5 instead of taking that but the
first novelty in this opening is what
bishi and on decided to play and in the
opening he played a night here to f7 so
this is you know he took a lot of time
on this move he kind of made the
decision that okay now is going to be
the time where I kind of go away and I
kind of get into my preparation for this
specific line and so magnus carlsen even
on his next move actually took a lot
more time than he had for any of his
previous moves because you realized okay
we're kind of going into you know
unchartered territory I need to make
sure that I'm as prepared going into
this battle because it looks like vision
on is playing this new Knight to f7 move
we now see the knight come up here to e3
centralizing just getting more involved
into the game right here a king over
there to d8
Knight to f5 pawn here to c5 Knight over
here to g3 and Magnus Carlsen is really
trying to find any sort of weakness in
vision on setup so this pawn right here
on f6 is definitely something that he
can attack so we could see the knight
come over here to h5 and then after h5
this bishop would come down here to g3
and then h4 and then all of a sudden
they have two minor pieces attacking the
square here on f6 so again there's not a
lot that either side can really do right
now there there's someone at a stalemate
just waiting for someone to slip up or
find a small advantage and so that's
what Magnus Carlsen is deciding to do he
sees a small little opening and so he
starts to go for it fishy and I thought
about it for a while and then played
Knight here to e5 this does put a little
stop to it you now aren't gonna see
Knight to h5 because now the bishop can
come up here to g8 where it couldn't
before this just adds some pressure on
Magnus Carlsen that doesn't want to have
and so instead of playing that decides
to go and bring this rook up here to h8
this checks the King also allows for
this bishop to not come to g8 anymore so
after the rook up here to g8 we now see
an exchange of the bishop and the knight
and then we see the rook come back here
to h5 so my name is Carson still wants
to play for the win so he brings his
rook back here to h5 and then all of a
sudden we see a very interesting move
from
chignon he decides to go ahead and
exchange off his minor piece his last
minor pieces bishop here on g4 in
exchange for two ponds so all of a
sudden magnus carlsen has the lead in
material he has a rook anna knights and
two ponds and his opponent has a rook
and four pawns so he's up a pawn in
material the problem for Magnus Carlsen
is although he's kind of up in material
it's very hard to turn this into a win
because he really wants one of his pawns
to promote you know these rooks kind of
cancel each other out you can't just win
with a knight that's not gonna get the
job done you need more material than a
knight that's a draw game so he needs to
find a way efficient on can go ahead and
take off these ponds then all of a
sudden magnus carlsen has lost pretty
much all opportunity to win the game
vision on on the other hand he could try
for even pushing for win himself he has
all these pawns over here if all of a
sudden you know Magnus Carlsen can't
really utilize his knight enough machine
on has more pawns he can push forward on
the Queen side go ahead and promote one
of those to a queen and easily win this
game so both sides getting into
potentially long endgame and just trying
to see if their opponents make a mistake
now open to this point
34 moves into the game about two and a
half hours have gone by now some of the
other games have lasted even to an F
hours so this is about the stopping
point that some of the matches go to but
this game would not be over for a while
we now see pawn here to b6 to
solidifying this pawn chain right here
Knight to e4 and we just see a lot of
different moves again Magnus Carlson's
goal is to try to make sure his King
safe try to make sure he doesn't lose
any pawns try to make sure his rook is
very centralized it controls a lot of
the board and then just dance his knight
all over the board hopefully he can
catch his opponent off guard maybe he
can snipe a few pawns here and there if
he's lucky fall for a huge mistake and
then all of a sudden he can get a rook
again on Vichy and on side the board
he's trying to gobble up these pawns
right here he's trying to make sure that
this pawn chain is solidified his Kings
not out in the open he's not getting too
attacked and his rook just kind of
swings back and forth attacking the King
making sure that my name is Crossin
doesn't do
too much so pawn here to d7 King to d2
so we kind of come through what kind of
rush through these moves there are a lot
of them and they're just small
incremental moves not too much to talk
about as we do see some checks and then
all of a sudden some incremental moves
every now and then we'll see a lot of
Knight moves to the center of the board
and then just this rook coming back here
on the e-file every now and then to
check and then every once in a while
we'll actually see a pawn move up the
board which is a little bit what Magnus
Carlsen is trying to do so we'll come
through a little bit more all of a
sudden the rook over on the F file
Magnus Carlsen is okay to exchange the
rooks off the board if he has two pawns
and a knight that's definitely going to
be a good in game for him
Abba chignon does not want to do that
and so Magnus cross ins do way needs to
do he's starting to slowly put pressure
on his opponent he recognizes that he's
playing an older challenger vichy and on
is not quite twice his age but about
twenty years his senior and so he just
wants to try to go to a long-long
endgame drag this out even if he doesn't
win this game he recognizes that this
could put pressure on his opponent to
make mistakes in future games because he
wasted so much energy on this game
fishing on on the other hand is very
good at defending and he's just trying
to hold on make sure he doesn't make
another mistake the last thing he wants
to do is go down to games in this series
pawn here to b5 trying to exchange some
of this material off the board again
vichy not just wants to get those pawns
off the board Knight to c3 pawn c6
moving the Knights trying to do anything
possible with this knight on board
trying to gobble up some material this
year now I'm just gonna dance this King
all over the board if we do see an
exchange so that's kind of a minor win
for vision on taking off one of the
ponds Magnus Carlsen is able to gobble
up upon himself and then all of a sudden
Sui come through would you see a check
and now that King comes down and takes
this pawn here on b3 so we kind of look
at this setup we are quite a few moves
in where 77 moves in all of a sudden
Magnus Carlsen he doesn't have an
more pawns and so if you kind of look at
this you say yes magnus carlsen is up in
material because the night is worth more
than two pawns but it's very difficult
for Magnus Carlsen or anyone else to
translate this into a win because you
just don't have the material you need
even though it is better than what your
opponent has now fishing on the other
side he could try to push forward with
his pawns it's gonna be very very
difficult that you can't really control
everything with just a rook when your
opponent has a knight that can dance all
over the board and also has a rook so
definitely looking like a draw-game but
both sides decide that they want to go
ahead and play it out
so the rook over here to a-1 decides to
go ahead and just concede one of his
pawns after a few moves so a few checks
we see the real cover here to h1 and now
we see the King come over here to d1
centralizing a little bit more moving
around the board at this pawn on here to
a3 could be potentially dangerous but
there's no real way to hold on to it
again the rook over here on h4 pretty
much a barrier for this King it can't
come past this fourth rank anymore so
there's no way to really hold on to this
material right here so after pawn here
to a2 we do see an exchange right here
so fishy and on you know his chances of
winning are definitely going very very
slim right now Magnus Carlsen a few
moves later is able to gobble up the
last pawn on board and so we see a
typical rook in Knights verse in game
very varied rolla in nature yes a
grandmaster has beaten a grandmaster in
this but it really just requires a huge
mistake so as long as this chignon
doesn't make a huge mistake at the end
of this we'll have a draw so we do see
many more moves again this was actually
one of the longest games in history it
was two moves away from the longest game
in World Championship history but after
a few more moves in the game we actually
do see an exchange of the rooks here on
c1 and after the Knight takes here on c1
the players agreed to draw there's not
sufficient material for white to win
here
the white is up in material and so if
you were to run it through a computer
the computer would say yes white is
definitely winning white can't win in
this position so this was a very long
game and ended up being six and a half
hours so you know after that 34 move
where you kind of looked at and said
okay this is probably gonna be a draw
that was two and a half hours they
played for four more hours so magnus
carlsen again I'm not even sure if he
wanted or obviously he wanted to win I'm
not even sure he thought that he could
win I think deep down he just wanted to
try to wear out his opponent for future
games he recognizes that he's up a game
and it's gonna be difficult for his
opponents to actually come back from
that deficit so if he can wear him out
right now going into a long end game
which he kind of knew this would that's
what happened so 122 moves to shy of the
record we do have a draw Magnus Carlsen
after game 7 is still up a game and one
of Vichy anon coming back tomorrow with
the white pieces and see if he can come
back and even things up so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video or enjoying the
matches so far definitely a long one but
very very fun to watch both players
playing till the very bitter end so
thanks for watching I'll see you guys in
the next one